SAM CHAUDHARY:
ClassDojo is a platform
that helps teachers
and parents build
character strengths with kids.
Teachers use the
ClassDojo mobile app
to give kids positive feedback
in the classroom for all
the things they're doing well.
And then they collect
all this data,
which they share
with parents at home.
LIAM DON: We probably
spoke to-- Sam actually
spoke to about 200
teachers on the phone.
What they kept telling us was
that they had this big problem
that they were facing
regarding behavior.
The more we talked
to them, the more
we became convinced
that this was something
that we had to tackle.
KALEN GALLAGHER:
It's crazy to think
that three years ago,
ClassDojo didn't exist.
And now I think there's close
to two million teachers who
use us.
We're in front of
around 40 million kids
everyday in 28 languages
in 148 countries.
The list goes on.
If teachers like something,
it will spread that quickly.
Teachers want to be able to
walk around the classroom
and perform without
being tied to a computer.
And so we started
looking at building
a native app for Google Play.
And with the launch of
Google Play for Education,
that was a natural
fit for us to dive in.
LIAM DON: So we want to reach
as many teachers as possible.
And what we found was
Google Play for Education
was a great way to
do that because we
have all this
visibility on the store.
We like the fact that we
can push instant updates
because that allows us to
respond to user demands
quite quickly.
I think one of my
top pieces of advice
for other developers in the
Google Play for Education store
is to really think about the
seasonality of education.
You'll see much better results
if you launch something
in the fall when
teachers are actually
making adoption decisions.
KALEN GALLAGHER: Localizing
the app makes a lot of sense.
Here in the United
States, there's
a lot of people who
are changing the app
language because their
native tongue is not English.
LIAM DON: It's really
important for them
to have a simple experience
that they can use very easily.
It's important for them to be
able to install your app easily
and sign into it very easily.
And that's where I think
Google Play for Education
has been really helpful.
SAM CHAUDHARY: I think one of
ClassDojo's proudest moments
was about two months ago when
we passed this amazing milestone
for the company, which
was a billion pieces
of positive feedback given
by teachers to students.
That was pretty exciting.